[Music]
all right in scary clown news Oh what
the hell submitted by just the tip that
gave never worked it's never just a tip
it's always more than the tip all in
baby the world clown Association has
complained that the movie it is hurting
real clowns man 1951 no wait there's a
world there's an association to hurting
their reputation no clowns first of all
your reputation is already ruined clown
[ __ ] because I hung out a lot of clowns
but insomnia phase we were performers oh
yeah my name is bozo seriously out with
clowns like where do you find this
groove insomniac all the ravers and
stuff all the performers like naked
female Gogol clowns no I mean like legit
like clowns would be higher for work and
stuff like like they juggle they walk on
stilts like it's [ __ ] like that like
Cirque stuffing seen that at every some
of them are clowns like something very
full towel a clown nose is like the
stuff on TV I don't count that's
talented [ __ ] people that's come on
now you want Modern Family cam how
serious is over he is about as close Oh
clowning that's right are there clown
schools I mean there's an association
magician schools like it's weird because
like no but like magicians are so
interesting cuz they want you to really
like what they're doing but if you don't
give a [ __ ] about them they get really
offended
I mean mind you like I didn't have a lot
of tact when I was younger so and this
is my man younger like three years ago
and some do comes up and he goes hey do
you believe in magic and all I said to
him was you're [ __ ] weird do you
believe in magic
trying to reel you in yeah you're
[ __ ] weird man
my yeah it would have been nice it feels
like hi my name is Steve and I do magic
can I show you something
yeah like a normal person yeah what the
[ __ ] yeah that would hump believe in
magic
[ __ ] you Merlin called his name is his
name's actually Rob and his business
card is Rob the magician parenthesis
please don't rob me that's just my name
Claire they're upset because now it is
coming back again I think it looks great
that it I can't watch them maybe the
first one you know what the second one
doesn't look as scary as one though it's
hard the first one was way scarier Kelly
are you talking about the old one like
in the 801 the one was the actor's name
who played in a screaming curry any why
Stephen Curry Stephanie hurry that's why
I got running Stephen yeah Tim Curry
yeah you think this new Pennywise is not
as scary as the old one he's too suave
look I mean I haven't seen the movie it
looks too young trailer
Wow Bob that is a quick for it trailer
all right it is a pretty close
oh really I'm freaked out oh no I'll see
this [ __ ] this [ __ ]
this scene was hilarious in the trailers
he runs into that he's like falling the
little boat in the water and he hits
himself on the I thought of the comedy
[Music]
it's a paper boat exactly that's not
terrifying you folks he doing in the
sewer
Pennywise yeah I don't remember it I was
doing bad things during those days oh
geez
oh what a pedophile
so what does he do yes what are you is
he a molester or what he eats children
eats children yeah and then they start
dreaming once you encounter him then the
kids when they go to sleep they dream of
him too he and he can enter your dreams
does it that's pretty clear it's weird
because I think I can't remember too
much I saw when I was like eight years
old but I think he's an alien
he's an alien so I saw the original from
1990 when I was already an adult and so
I saw that and I'm like this is
hilarious this is such a bad movie I
thought it was so funny I'm like how is
this carrier because you're older
yeah I think so I think and there's like
parts - were there's like the shower
thing there's like a sink thing and it's
part when you open a book and the book
starts coming up [ __ ] freaked me out
I can't read books and I can't shower
now
I [ __ ] shampoo with Milo but you have
any idea how painful it is mm yes yeah
and this is a 1991 looks it's just the
teeth if they combined the makeup like
the way the new one looks with that
[ __ ] mouth and it's he that would be
terrifying used to swab this guy's like
- looks like a joker [ __ ] bad-ass yo
don't scare me that money well searching
this image right and I was alone in the
kitchen cuz you were upstairs no no I
kept hearing noises behind me like why
am I getting scared on this guy that's
Gary right he doesn't like you you're
too old scarier to me than this guy this
guy looks like if you're watching one of
those videos right where you're like
following the car and then it pops out I
don't know that's the one that scared
would you be more afraid of this one
this is like more crudely done like a
real psychopath too much it's like two
comic book-y
I see okay the old one looks like a real
real you can see everyday in the yeah
okay this one is like really good art
yeah
but I think this is great why are they
getting worked up now clowns have always
had a bad rap rap even ever since this
old one and like what's it you've been
worked up and now we're just talking
about it oh I see there's like the
killer set murderer was that murder that
dressed up as a clown
John Basie John Wayne Gacy he was a
serial killer
yeah bozo super bozo Pogo or pogo pogo
yeah
he killed kids I know you killed run-ups
even an American Horror Story when the
circus one they had that clown and
there's just so many bad clown
representatives and so the clown
Association is just upset and they're
saying that their association has slowly
been losing member all so they had about
3,000 something members back then and
then now it's like it's just dwindling I
imagine they're protesting well I just
don't pretty I just don't think that's
because of the cloud movie I think it's
just you're a clown
people grow how to miss it's getting
outdated do people even get clowns at
birthday parties come on Omega Dora the
Explorer's youtubers to come out to your
[ __ ] kids [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
happy kids and yada you don't be a [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh yeah that's true they get guys
to like cosplay spider-man Superman
old-fashioned clowns are dying out for
same people though I hate clowns but I
don't want clowns have died out because
it's just a part of history you know
what I mean I like I hate you guys but
you guys can't die out though if gets
that well I think it's kind of sad
because it's like they're the clowning
the professional clowns that in this
whole clowning industry they're they're
really passionate about their job and
all about spreading happiness and like a
good message to kids and then so seeing
how they just had a bad rap I know see
50 clowns coming out of a Fiat I were
like they were legit they loved it so
much
yeah they try to spread happiness
they're like hippies almost that's what
sucks because the clown Association is
all about positivity all these other
things like American Horror Story it the
clown whatever
it's all scary [ __ ] it is and then also
recently you know how we were having all
those clown sightings oh the killer
clown yeah there were people that would
buy like horror clown masks and they'll
just be standing like randomly I'm just
trying to figure out how a clown face
makeup is supposed to make you laugh
like there's no real creepy as [ __ ] like
if I was at a McDonald's of Ronald
McDonald's just like hi because these
movies made it scary exactly back in a
day it probably looked goofy Oh accented
lips and last year's and like big yeah
yeah Mickey Mouse back that was [ __ ]
terrifying
I felt better eating next to the
Hamburglar that's why they had to make
grimace she's like Amelia Earhart with a
she's always got like flying yeah her
knee knows don't give a [ __ ] my [ __ ]
there was the two little things too the
little burger fries yeah they're like I
don't know they're like yeah I forgot
the names of them
I like the crew though I missed the gang
I missed the chairs the hamburger chairs
you get to sit on in the kids area I
will say this though [ __ ] McDonald's man
sponsored me first it was Jo now it's
you David nah man it's like I just can't
keep on being thirsty for [ __ ] four
years yeah I mean my thirst is gone now
Wendy's what's up my thirst nose down
the reason why we stuck with McDonald's
is we can't agree on other things
you know cuz he's done you know what
they they retweeted me that one time cog
oh yeah what'd you say and they very
tweeted that tweet nice is creep hard on
him so is there a way to rebrand clowns
than you think I think we gotta make a
movie I make a movie yeah I think what
we have to do is like shine some
positivity
clowns and make a whole movie about
crime-fighting clowns oh you know what
type of movie I want to do them with
clowns I want to do one like not like
stomp the yard but what's called one of
those dance battle movies Tommy the
clown he's about the hanger she's about
the hang his nose up and then one his
homeys comes through right he goes yo
man you make kids laugh you don't stop
this huh
what are these kids could it do he's
like you right the circus is almost
pulling out the the ribbons and [ __ ]
it's like you guys on a huge stage
trying to make each other laugh it's
like a dance movie trope yeah it's like
a clown save the rec center me yeah they
gotta have a female interest like they
always do a hot clown only one that
believed in him is [ __ ] your shoes are
too small I think you need these clowns
like it's parents fault too as two white
kids don't really like clowns anymore
these days because when you don't like
clowns our generation no my clowns
yeah cuz when they have a clown at the
party or whatever they'll force the kid
on the count my go go say hi and then
the kids just say you know I don't want
it and then they they get Tom type and
then they grow up and then they're
teaching their kids I clowns they're
scarier what a lousy to give presents
that's what it is because I feel like
kids parents do the same thing to kids
for Santa Claus yeah talk to you and his
old scary man's gonna talk to you but
what's the saving grace for Santa
presents yeah yeah yeah Hollywood they
don't really tarnish then either because
they have been making horror film Santa
Claus is now have you seen Futurama
Santa Claus no yeah but the cons are
saying that - like with what Santa and
everyone else I it will hurt an actual
industry that makes a lot of money off
of it people
make money off of clowns so then that's
why clowns are just easy to revitalize
the circus then because it searches the
dining out to make sexy clowns clowns
what might help you take off the face
makeup and then I think you might be
okay no but no the [ __ ] big overalls
are funny the big shoes that Hong Kong
just take the [ __ ] face makeup and I
guarantee you it's gonna revitalize your
whole thing cuz then I'll invite you to
my birthday redo the makeup cuz I saw
his girl clown she her makeup is so cute
like she looks really cute maybe get rid
of all the white paint and just draw the
cute stuff on it yeah keep the fake keep
the face complexion there's so your
shows your human at least yeah I think
they need to rethink why they're clowns
and what they're doing because because
obviously the clowns are there to make
people happy right I'm already happy as
[ __ ] every day I don't need you to make
me happy it's very good
but still we're the ones that get them
right we gotta get I gotta I'm never
gonna get a compliment baby girl your
stripper new [ __ ] there we go they
make you happy give the lollipop out of
her tits what's up you sexy [ __ ]
useless [ __ ] [ __ ] if you
want to follow us you could check out
all our [ __ ] links in the description
box below you [ __ ] [ __ ]
other than that videos are up there
[Music]